you know there's a entire culture on
these platforms right so like tick-tock
is a great example where there's
obviously the tick-tock influencers
there are certain ways that people use
it and you wrote an article about even
the way that people use certain
functionality and one of them was like
the live-streaming while people are
sleeping maybe talk a little bit about
just like that seems like such like a
nuance to use case for a platform where
most older people would like be
horrified at the idea of that whereas
some of these influencers had really
kind of understood like hey this is a
unique way to use the platform yeah it's
funny so back in 2015 I was obsessed
with this live streaming app called
you now and I would make my friends go
on it all the time it never honestly
really took off but there was there were
you know influencers some of them became
users that are not tick stalkers but um
you know it was another live streaming
platform where the benefit was to sort
of stream as long as possible but
obviously it's very hard to fill content
for that amount of hours then there was
this this trend that started called
sleep squad that took off among people
and it kind of became this thing that
people did which is livestream
themselves sleeping and then now we see
it on Twitch and tick tock and it's kind
of a thing it's kind of a meme and it's
a joke it's like can i hey how many
followers can I get you know when I'm
sleeping but it's also a way to like go
viral because it's so funny and because
what it does is provide these sort of
pop-up chat rooms so it's like it's kind
of like a lot of people also just stream
an inanimate object and what they're
doing is really just they want to get
that like chat going and then people
just start connecting and chatting and
having this whole thing through within
this pop-up chat on the live stream and
so that's the appeal for users that are
watching it it's not that yeah it's a
darkroom someone sleeping and that's
kind of funny for a second but you're
also able to kind of like chat you know
with these other people in a way that
you wouldn't you know have access to so
it's sort of like these little ephemeral
chat rooms yeah and it seems like
part of that these applications aren't
being used solely for the videos right
so like the tic TOCs for example you can
sit and I think it's really unique how I
put the platform together in terms of
you kind of just scroll and and continue
to see video after video after video and
if you're just using it for the first
couple of times like that's kind of the
surface use case but the comments and
kind of all of these subcultures within
the platform aren't very obvious is that
something going back to like the younger
demographic is just all of their friends
are doing it and they kind of learn it
by talking to each other or is it
something that you just actually like
the time on the application itself
drives you to use some of the other
features you know that's something that
I would love like data from Instagram on
for instance I wrote about like comment
culture on Instagram a couple years ago
and it's hugely driven by teenagers I
mean if you go in the comments of a lot
of stuff it's like meme accounts people
trying to get you know publicity and
then a lot of teenagers or young people
primarily I mean of course they're still
like you know other just teenagers that
comment but but they really do engage in
that way um and I don't know I you know
I don't know if that just has to I don't
know if it's driven specifically by time
spent but I imagine part of it is the
culture like tagging friends responding
to things and I think a lot of young you
know stars on Instagram also have more
interesting comment sections yeah it
feels like you know in instagrams I
think a perfect example where you see
the comments but then there's also like
a whole nother layer of usage where
people take the photos or videos that
are posted they DM them into these
groups and they have these group chats
around that and it's like that
conversation is more protected it's
private it's with that kind of a
selective group of friends but that is
almost the same type of thing that
happens in the comments to some degree
yeah I mean I think both are places to
socialize I mean the benefit of DM is
that you can share links you know you
have a set group of people I hear of
people meeting in the comments a lot and
I think there's like somebody that was
saying that they met friends actually in
a common
of the comments by slab page because
there's all these like comments by
accounts now that are really popular to
that sort of highlight some of the best
parts the comments section so I think
people are kind of going there to make
connections find people with similar
interests and then hop into group chats
there's so many interest based group
chats you know that people are involved
in on Instagram and I get added to them
a lot and I love it
and so I just yeah I just think it's
another way to socialize I think that
you know a lot of users that are maybe
more adults I don't know someone I mean
I know some moms that have Instagram
group chats but I think they're also
more likely to use things like iMessage
yes speaking of moms one of the trends
that just blows me away is on tick tock
these kids who are pulling their parents
and especially now because most of them
are home and their parents are growing
like pretty big audiences I simply by
dancing in videos with their kids right
similar to kind I think how about vine
stars all made each other famous now
kids are just doing it with like the
closest adults them who just happens to
be their middle aged parent I know I
wrote a piece a couple weeks ago about
sort of like how it's all family
tick-tock now because everyone's
involving every member of their family I
saw a girl just this morning celebrating
she was giving her father a cake because
he had it a hundred thousand so it's
yeah it's it's been fun I think
everybody you know when you like an
influencer you like a certain person on
ticket talk you like to kind of follow
everyone in their orbit whether that's
their close friends or their family
their family usually are the ones that
have that kind of like behind-the-scenes
access to them and posts you know funny
videos and you know a bunch of the big
tik-tok influencers have kind of
transformed their whole family into
influencers like Addison Rae her whole
family and Charlie D'Amelio obviously
like Mark D'Amelio is like an influence
around to himself now yeah and I guess
part of that is so Charlie D'Amelio is I
think one of the first ones that I saw
where she's now got 50 million followers
give or take cause yeah Wow and and so
she's famous her sister's famous her
dad's famous and her mom's name it's
rhymey literally the entire family and
they all got signed by UTA together like
as a unit so maybe let's talk a little
bit just about like the business behind
a lot of this cuz it's you know it's
kind of fun in games to see people post
the content and grow but there's really
really big businesses that are being
built here just kind of at a high level
like how do you think about you know the
commercialization or the business behind
all of it yeah I think that's what a lot
of people sort of don't understand is
the business behind it
and one how much work it takes to grow
that business and to this sort of like
ancillary businesses that are built up
around the influencer industry I mean
you mentioned agents a lot of you know
the big Hollywood agencies all have very
robust digital divisions that sign you
know people like the de mille o--'s
hoping to turn them into essentially the
next Kardashians or sort of growth you
know grow their brand even bigger
collectively
but then you also have all of these
other people that support influencers
you know you have kids that just make
money essentially by helping influencers
optimize their YouTube thumbnails and
editing them and a certain way to get
them clicks or you have you know
somebody that runs a brand marketing
platform that just partners brands with
influencers there's like a lot of sort
of businesses that are helped is through
so we've set up to help support the
influencer economy it's not just like
traditional entertainment businesses
like managers agents you know acting
coaches singing coaches a lot of these
people have those people also in network
but yeah it's it's crazy because I think
you know when you get into the game of
hey just creating content one thing but
Nelson we're gonna start optimizing the
thumbnail right we're actually going to
strategically place you in videos with
other influencers to cross-promote
accounts and and it almost feels like a
lot of this loses the authenticity but
the ones who are really good at it
they're able to kind of hide the
business a little bit behind this how
much of that is being driven by the kids
themselves and like they want it to be a
business versus they've got a family
member or somebody near them who's a
little bit more professional or you know
experience that that's driving it yeah
their family members absolutely are
never more experienced than these kids
these kids on
and monetization on digital platforms
better than truly I would say almost any
digital marketing executive a lot of
them and if you look at people like
David Goldberg or James Charles Wright
both of whom are very young influencers
you know they're not teenagers I think
James is like 20 in David's 23 or
something you know they are they have
teams around them but they're incredibly
adapt at staying on top of the trends
you know getting in early and promoting
themselves on these new platforms
growing their audiences and they really
do want to make it a full-time career
and that's it's you know I would say
being an influencer content creator or
whatever you're essentially an
entrepreneur right you're running your
own small business often that that
business is your personal brand but you
know it can also just be an
interest-based account that you run you
know if you're a car vlogger and you
just post about cars all day you know
you can end up sort of running
essentially a little content company
about cars right and so I think like any
small business owner you know these
people work really hard they understand
their business better than anyone and
it's usually much it's driven from them
because if you have some outside person
you know that can help motivate you to a
point but it really has to come from you
if you want the businesses succeed